fin de semana de críticas internas en el
que algunos Aliados del presidente
Vladimir Putin han pedido Incluso el uso
de armas nucleares tácticas en Ucrania
por fin el cremen ha roto su silencio el
portavoz del presidente Putin Dimitri
fresco ha dicho que este tipo de
armamento se usará siguiendo la doctrina
nuclear rusa que contempla dos
escenarios para el uso de Estas armas en
primer lugar en el caso de un ataque con
armas de destrucción masiva contra Rusia
o contra cualquiera de sus aliados o si
no en el caso de que peligre la
existencia de Rusia como estado Por
cierto interesante también que poco
antes de que la duma votase la anexión
de los cuatro nuevos territorios por fin
el portavoz de Putin ha respondido a la
pregunta sobre dónde acaban esas nuevas
fronteras de Rusia en unos territorios
que su ejército no no controla
completamente
En todo caso seguirán consultando a la
población y que dependerá en buena
medida de la voluntad de los locales